uh hi i'm tim schafer and i'll be
answering 23 questions give or take a
couple
[Music]
who's tim schafer uh
tim schaefer talks about himself in the
third person he is the studio head of
double fine productions and he's made
video games for about 30 years
but uh he's young at heart
what does tim stand for i stand for i
try to you know i try to stand up for um
creativity and games i'll say you know
trying to uh fight for games being as
creative as possible and for the team
having a quality of life that's as high
as possible
what is the second odd the psychonaut
in the case of the game psychonauts the
psychonaut is an international secret
agent who has psychic powers that they
use to perform amazing acts of espionage
what is this psychonaut outside
psychonauts in general is a term that
refers to any explorer of the
psychedelic space so
some people who take uh hallucinogenic
drugs consider themselves psychonauts
some people who just through meditation
or other altered states expand their
consciousness
will name themselves psychonauts but
in the game
psychonauts
it's something else
we just made it 24 questions brilliant
great
hi i'm tim schafer i'll be answering 24
questions
[Music]
my morning routine well it's all changed
since uh quarantine and quivered i i got
into some good habits where i would just
wake up and have some coffee and some
toast and i would do jigsaw puzzles for
a while
and then i would oh for a while i was
doing like this exercise bike it was a
really good time then i discovered
instead of doing all that i could
actually just make a breakfast and watch
tv and that's been my worst morning
routine but i try
to just wake up and do jigsaw puzzles
and do that exercise bike that's my
that's my publicly stated routine i'll
go with that
my creative routine
that also takes discipline and my
creative routine um varies on uh
depending on how good i'm being the good
version of my creative routine is like
wake up and i get right to my desk and i
sit down before i talk to anyone or have
any thoughts and i do free writing in my
notebook where you just write for a
certain amount of time and don't think
and don't edit and don't do anything but
keep your pen moving and right right
i've had periods where i come up with a
lot of ideas during that phase and then
sometimes getting bad habits um like
right now we're busy shipping a game so
i'm not doing that so much every morning
but i'm gonna get back to it look my
notebook's right over there tomorrow
morning tomorrow morning whole new start
for me
how many people's favorite games have i
made
how many people's favorite come do how
many total fans do we have how many
students
uncountable i um
i don't know if i actually understand
exactly the question but i will try to
answer that i you know every time we're
making a game where
we put as much love and heart into it as
if we're making someone's favorite game
because there's a chance that every game
you make is someone's favorite game and
so i think you should treat it with that
much responsibility
my first job i mean i sold newspapers i
was really young i was ushering a movie
theater
worked in a computer store
i worked on a turkey ranch
but my first real job out of college was
at lucas arts so
once all those
other jobs were out of the way my first
job was great
fame ramon's album i've always liked the
end of the century because it starts off
so it's just so great
[Music]
and also that was my i think the first
one i heard and you know it's often with
these things the first thing you heard
really like blows your mind and
like so trying it in jungle i like the
um the older one that has judy's a punk
on it i don't know there's a lot of good
ones
i have them all downstairs i just put
them on little plastic
protective cases that's how nerdy i'm
getting most listened to album while
writing psychonauts too
oh my gosh i didn't want to say
they were different albums when i was
writing like grim fandango and full
throttle
and uh on psychonauts two i listened to
a lot of my discover weekly uh playlist
on spotify which brought a lot of weird
uh
songs into my repertoire but um yeah i
was trying to listen to a lot of new
music and strange music
but i still i have a playlist
uh on spotify just my favorite metal
songs and i listen to them over and over
again because i know them so well
they're very not distracting they're
very they help me focus so my metal
playlist on spotify i think is what was
the most which is public go ahead and
check it out the best metal if i weren't
in games i'd obviously be
uh in a rock band i'm super cool like
that but uh likely i mean i didn't know
i could get a job in games and so i was
learning computer science so i could be
a database programmer so maybe i'd get
a sad database programmer i mean that's
a good job i don't mean to put that i
mean if you're a database programmer
you're not sad i'm not i'm just saying i
compared to
doing what i do now i would personally i
shouldn't have answered this question
[Music]
that's my answer
most unusual interests i mean my
interests are pretty mundane i mean i do
like it during quarantine i've gone into
jigsaw puzzles and retro video games and
i really liked when i was a kid i was
really obsessed with rubber stamps you
know like rubber stuff would collect
rubber stamps was a little inked rubber
stamps like catalogs of them i would
study them i would
uh oh man
that was a weird hobby what character
have you made that you relate to the
most
i mean obviously eddie riggs is
basically based on me my muscles and
everything one of the challenges is
making characters that aren't you
because i think a lot of people are just
writing in their own voice when they
write a character they write like they
talk and i think you've got to make a
character that's really specific and
real and is alive and is different from
you you know i was really surprised when
i was writing grim fandango that manny
calaveras said a lot of things about his
philosophy and life and it's like that's
not mine i wonder where that's coming
from that just comes from kind of manny
talking to you bound only by the
paper-thin wrapper of mortality a soul
here lies
struggling to be free and so it shall
thanks to a bowl of bad gaspacho
what's the deal with the receptionist in
the psycho isolation chamber that's
terrible she's just really friendly and
she's been isolated for a long time and
she wants to talk to someone i tell you
i have been waiting for someone to come
visit for a long time
i was starting to think i was invisible
you ever get that feeling and she um
uh wants to guess your name because
she's just trying to make conversation
and depending what the player does they
can totally ignore poor terrell and it
just makes her keep guessing she really
is she's doing the work she's doing the
work to reach out and um you can talk to
her you can ignore her that's the
player's choice but i think you should
talk to her i feel bad for her can you
believe he even finds me overwhelming
what's the deal with sasha 9. that's a
piece of missing dialogue that uh people
don't
know because i never actually wrote it
down
ah oh so tacky i can't look directly at
it sasha has kind of a bauhaus style
and he uh doesn't like
um cheap
imitation tiffany lamps but real nice
examples of craftsman era mid-century
stained glass lamps need his approval
and he has one in his office in psychons
too so he likes the real deal he likes
the crafting movement but he doesn't
like cheap uh doily type imitation
tiffany lamps
it's a bad taste
what has linda been up to well i imagine
linda has been hanging out with uh mr
pokelope and what name is that noble
lake creature
[Music]
what a magical lady
and sitting in the mud and you know
forming her little muka sack to protect
her from the dry spells of the weather
and watching a lot of tv
stealing kids brains no she doesn't do
that anymore she's reformed
have you always known the story for
psychonauts too actually at the end of
psychonauts one
i had about half the ideas that appear
in psychonauts too i had the ideas a lot
of stuff that happens with ford with
stuff that's been planned since 2005 and
um things about the water curse were
going to be in psychonauts one but um
that uh
that got cut but now we have it inside
outs too and it's really nice that
people can finally find out
how did raz get that curse on his family
to die in water um but there are also a
lot of new ideas that came out and a lot
of the family backstory those names were
all written down in 2005 for his family
but a lot of new plot points came out
with a new team all brainstorming about
the story so a little mix of old and new
there
hardest part of writing
[Music]
hardest part writing is writing oh my
god i can't talk the hardest part of
writing is talking
i'm not gonna make it through all these
questions
45 questions whoever asks 45 questions
um the hardest part of writing is
sitting down your desk to write that's
really it's a habit thing like putting
in the work to actually
put pen to paper um takes some
discipline
um and then when you're actually you do
the work to do the backstory all the
characters get to know them the actual
writing can kind of flow you know you're
doing a lot of dialogue then there's a
lot of because of the way that i do it
for games and they get a lot of
backstory and then just touch on that
backstory various points in the game and
some of the hardest points near the end
of the game is remembering have i
explained everything you need to know
about the backstory or are people gonna
be really confused and we play test
psychonauts too there are a couple of
major plot points i was like oh that's
right we never explained that so-and-so
was related to so-and-so and so i had to
go back and add some dialogue to explain
some plot points so it's important to
play test you're writing
what would your brain level theme be
oh that's like that's a level of
interest introspection that i don't know
if i'm capable of i mean you go in my
brain
um
right now it's filled with cats because
there's cats all over this house and
yeah they kind of get into places they
shouldn't be like my brain
um i think a lot about video games uh
i don't know exactly what my brain
looked like inside my brain but uh no
mushrooms that's for sure no mushrooms
i hate mushrooms
biggest inspiration for psychology
besides psychonauts one i assume you
know there's a lot of different
inspirations for psychonauts too um in
psychonauts one was actually inspired a
lot of like a psychology of dreams class
i took in college and also some um hong
kong movies with a little
martial arts master that was only like
10 years old which were inspiring from
rats and for psychonauts 2 they are
you know whereas the first game relied a
lot on freudian psychology i think the
science 2 has a lot of jungian
psychology if you will just to sound
super
pretentious about it there's also
inspirations like yellow submarine and
there's inspirations like
you're gonna cut this part out i'm quiet
right
i don't wanna say something about
polling oh i forgot to turn off my
notifications
have the biggest impact on you i mean so
many games that have had a huge impact
on me in the in the early days like
super mario 64 had this like
made me really open up about what worlds
could be like to explore and feel like
all the way to breath of the wild like
it's very inspirational like exploration
is something i care about a lot and
those games had a huge um impact on me
how quickly can i solve a ruse cube one
minute and 30 seconds i can't get any
faster than that i don't know why i keep
trying to get faster than uh in 90
seconds but i cannot break that don't
time it right now
here i can i can set a timer hold on i
don't know if i can actually do this in
a minute let's just try
shuffle shuffle
don't start the timer yet you get a look
at it i don't know what i'm doing i'm
not actually going to
memorize it or anything like that okay
ready and good
[Music]
[Music]
should be faster this part
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
now is all for nothing
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
uh
a minute and 20 seconds oh i made it yes
new record minute 20.
yeah
take that blindfolded kid you can do it
in six seconds
[Laughter]
well thank you for uh being here for
this historic record-breaking moment uh
i hope you enjoyed listening to these
questions however many of them they were
um
and uh
thanks for watching
oh this is the first time i've done
roots cube during the interview for time
really official timing yeah
[Music]
you